[Music]
it's seven o'clock you're watching sky
news tonight on a special question and
answer program on the war in ukraine
the headlines president zielinski says
his country is on the brink of surviving
the war but the moscow's atrocities
continue
there are russian troops who are killing
and raping people and kidnapping
children torturing people and looting
ukrainian forces prepare the pushback
claiming to have russian troops
surrounded in several key positions
outside kiev
but claims of russian war crimes
continue a school in kharkiv and a
children's hospital in luhansk crumbling
under fire
and the strategic port city of mariopol
still stands against the russian siege
but about 300 000 people are now said to
be without water
[Music]
good evening well uh tonight we hope to
answer as many of your questions as
possible on day 27 of this war in
ukraine coming up in just a moment the
latest from the current focus of
fighting mario paul but first let's uh
bring in our defense and security
analyst michael clark who's going to be
answering all your questions this
evening and uh michael as we're saying
that it's almost a month since the
invasion began what stands out for you
and how it's all playing out
well it's not working out the way
anybody thought it would at least of all
president putin
i guess we're into what i would describe
as sort of stage three of the war now i
mean stage one was an attempt to be
clever on the russia's russia's part and
grab ukraine within 48 hours that didn't
work stage two was an attempt to
actually conduct a war maneuver and do
it the hard way that hasn't worked so
we're on to stage three now which is
attrition where he'll just grind it out
and that the political effect of that as
well as the effect on civilians is
beginning to emerge as we as the days go
on so we're getting reports on that
grinding it out we're getting reports of
trenches being dug minefields being laid
this means they're in for the long haul
it's in some respects it's beginning to
look like a very 20th century war with
lots of 21st century elements um and it
doesn't look as if it will be over soon
okay michael thank you very much indeed
as i've been saying we'll be putting uh
plenty of your questions to michael
during the course of the next hour but
the focus of the conflict for the past
week has been the city of mariopol
vladimir putin sees the southern port
town as a key strategic target for the
invasion and sky's charlotte lomas has
this report
one after another the bombs fall
this time the target is an industrial
center in maripo
factories that once provided jobs
destroyed in an instant marropol has
been under constant fire for weeks
homes across the city reduced to ruin
officials say around 90 percent of
buildings have been damaged here
the incessant fighting has forced these
ukrainian families to flee
but with nowhere to go they line their
cars along one of the city's roads the
russian word for children clearly marked
on windows
hoping this
might keep them safe
but in this besieged city it seems
anything goes
russians have attacked hospitals schools
a theater
these satellite pictures show the vast
extent of destruction
time is running out for people trapped
inside this city as food water and
medicine are scarce
three hundred thousand people in
mariupol
without food it's not the war anymore
and in the siege city
we clearly see that russia wants to
start hunger just to enforce its
diplomatic position on the diplomatic
processes
and what's that russia does
as the russian onslaught continues
there's increasing despair among global
leaders
this war is unwinnable
sooner or later it will have to move
from the battlefield to the peace table
and that is inevitable
the only question is how many more lives
must be lost
how many more bombs must fall
or many mario poles must be destroyed
meanwhile ukraine's leader remains
defiant but is yet again calling for
help from europe speaking to the italian
parliament this time zlensky warned the
russian advance won't stop at ukraine
we are now on the brink of survival
ukraine for russian troops is the
gateway into europe where they want to
break in but this barbarism must be
stopped
you know who brought this war to ukraine
those who are supporting this war all of
them are using italy as a place for
holidays so please don't be a holiday
resort to murderers
in turkey it certainly wasn't a warm
welcome for one of putin's friends
don't let him come to this place
ukrainian protesters here on a small
motorboat try to stop roman abramovich's
super yacht from docking and while
allies of putin are facing sanctions
abroad it's nothing compared to his
enemies at home
alexei navalny long-time critic of the
kremlin has been sentenced to nine years
in jail for fraud he was already serving
a two and a half year sentence at a
russian prison camp
he denies all the charges and says
they're politically motivated
in russia there can only be one voice
any opinions that don't toe the line are
silenced
charlotte lomas sky news
now just before we get to your questions
to michael clark let me take you through
today's other key developments in
ukraine people in the capital kiev have
been ordered to stay at home or in
shelters and a 35-hour curfew will be in
place until 7 a.m tomorrow morning
more than three and a half million
people have now fled ukraine and an
estimated six and a half million people
have been displaced within the country
the american president joe biden who's
due to travel to brussels has warned
american companies that they're likely
now to be targeted by russian cyber
attacks
and ukraine's president has accused
russian forces of looting and of
kidnapping children
the main development so far let's get
back now then to professor michael clark
and the questions that you've been
sending in to us all day so many of them
we're going to take a selection our
first one comes from hazel who asks this
what is it going to take for the world
to help ukraine militarily uh well
michael it would never be the world but
uh the west or nato what would it take
well it is it is already helping
militarily in all sorts of ways by
giving the ukrainians the best weapons
we have got that they can handle i mean
these end laws these new uh light
anti-tank weapons which are 90 effective
very high level we've basically given
the ukrainians all of ours we've given
them our whole stock so we don't have
any at the moment it doesn't matter
because we'll be getting more um but but
essentially the western nato has given
the ukrainians everything
at the level at which they can use now
certain things they can't use because
they need more training on them or
whatever and they may not be appropriate
but everything that's appropriate that
they can use we've given them so the
west is involved militarily but i know
what hazel's getting at which is you
know at what point would the west or the
the rest of the world move into ukraine
to fight for the ukrainians and
i can't see where that that well
i mean discussion of no-fly zones and of
course many warnings over the past week
or so from the united states from
president biden from our own country
about the use potential use by russia of
chemical and biological weapons would
that be some kind of red line it would
certainly be a red line because chemical
are a weapon of mass destruction and
that's pretty important and president
biden has said there'll be very severe
consequences he hadn't spelt out what
they would be and we don't know if that
would involve uh involvement
of military western military hardware in
ukraine i suspect it wouldn't i think
it'll just be more of the same at a much
higher level and a level of anger and
and resentment uh against president
putin that's my own view um so i don't
know what it would take um but remember
that president putin is trying to widen
this war he's trying to goad nato into
attacking him so that he can say to his
russian peoples look this is all about
defending ourselves from the west the
west is making war on russia i've been
telling you this for years now they're
doing it we've got to be very careful we
don't fall into that trap and as a very
good military historian friend of mine
alan malinson said he said we've got to
concentrate on winning cold war ii that
we've been pitched into not starting
world war iii so as bad as this war gets
and it will get worse yet we've got to
avoid a more general european war in
europe okay michael thank you for that
well uh let's talk more about military
tactics then on the ground this one
coming from aaron uh and uh aaron asks
well yeah well we ask this every week
that we've been doing these questions
and answers don't we what happened to
the 40 mile convoy or however long it
was or is of russian military vehicles
outside kiev is it still there and you
know why hasn't it been bombed to
smithereens most of it is because it was
most of it was a logistics convoy which
is carrying fuel and ammunition and food
and so on to the battle groups the btw
the btgs were the battalion tactical
groups we would call them battle groups
but the btgs
in russian versions and those btgs have
fanned out a bit to the west trying to
encircle kiev from the west and
southwest they haven't managed it and so
the convoy is still there and what the
ukrainians have done is they've fixed it
in place
sometimes on a battlefield you you don't
want to try and destroy everything
because you can't you don't have enough
troops and if you're surrounded as in a
national sense the ukrainians are
there's no phrase you've got to outgun
them somewhere right you have to have
gundam somewhere so there are parts of
the battlefront where you can't take
them on you've just got to fix them in
place so they don't move and what
ukraine has done is very clever they've
moved in with local offensives they've
gone for the fuel vehicles the logistics
so they've made it so that the convoy
can't actually move very much and it's
not much use to these btgs which are
actually fanning out to the west now if
western air power had that convoy to
mercy they would have destroyed it in an
afternoon but the ukrainians don't have
western air power and the fact that it's
been attacked and frozen does that take
us way back to the start of the conflict
and just show us how confident the
russians thought they were they didn't
seem to have proper support in place
they didn't have infantry in
the fields and woods beside it mopping
up the attackers absolutely air support
mechanized infantry should go ahead of
the armor in order to actually flush out
all the the ambush points um they didn't
do that so the armor went down one road
and these ukrainian ambushes sometimes
just 30 meters away just waiting for the
go pass it was like a duck shoot now of
course it's very dangerous to get within
30 meters of a t-72 tank and so as soon
as you fired off your end law or
whatever it is javelin you've got to get
out the way very very quickly but the
fact is that that the the ukrainians
have conducted a classic defense which
is not to try and hold a line because
you can't ever hold a line against
superior forces really what they've done
is the classic thing is they've mounted
small effective attacks at key points of
weakness in the superior forces facing
them that's good old-fashioned military
doctrine attacked them in several places
that really hurts them and in the case
of the convoy they've fixed it in place
so although they haven't destroyed it
it's not very much used to the russians
at the moment and
until the russians get more
reinforcements i mean they've basically
they've used about half of their total
ground forces in this operation so far
and they're beginning to mobilize the
other half of their ground forces which
you'll not be surprised to hear are not
the best they've used the best so now
they're mobilizing the rest
um as and when the numbers come in you
know they will have some effect let's
get more now uh through a question from
michael uh from cardiff uh about this
support that the west as you mentioned
there michael in terms of weapons in the
main is giving ukraine and michael asks
quite simply how does the process of
supplying weapons to ukraine actually
work
is it safe now presumably there's a lot
about that that even if you do know it
we you know we certainly wouldn't talk
about it we certainly can't talk about
it but you know what what can we talk
about we know that vast amounts of
weaponry is being supplied that it's
getting to the ukrainians so
how does that work yeah i mean just
going on what is publicly announced and
that's we can talk about that that's
fair enough um a lot of weaponry has
been going in through poland because
that's the biggest land border with
ukraine some of it is believed probably
to be going in through romania as well
because that's another good land board
and they're both nato countries of
course so when you say is it safe um
no once something is on the um on the
ukrainian side of the border of course
the russians will attack it if they see
it if they find it and if they can
attack it so we would assume that these
weapons supplies have been fairly
distributed and fairly clandestine and
so on the other thing that the west has
been doing is bringing
ukrainian troops out into poland or
romania or one of the other countries
for training and i mean again it's it's
public knowledge as of a couple of days
ago that we're giving them britain is
giving them star streak which is a very
effective anti-aircraft system but now
star streak normally takes months of
training
but we're going to try and we said the
british troops are there they're going
to try and train ukrainian operators in
two to three weeks crash course a
british operator normally has to go on a
simulator
and do a thousand hits they have to they
have to work a thousand hits and get
most of them before they're trained for
star streak so they're going to try and
do it in a crash course we'll see how
they get on but importantly we're not
just giving them star streak we're
giving them the simulator so that they
can start to train up their own people
so if this war does last for a while it
is reasonable to assume that ukrainian
teams will get better on a very complex
system which we wouldn't have thought
was possible about a month ago what can
star street do that other systems can't
it's it's very good against fast
low-flying aircraft you know the
russians at the moment they're flying
their aircraft not high because they
fear the sam tens which the ukrainians
have got so they're flying low at night
in ones and twos they're not flying
complex operations basically they're
taking off flying delivering their
weapons and flying back again back into
inside russia and low-flying fast
aircraft are very hard to hit from the
ground but star streak can get them it's
very very fast very effective but
believe me it requires some real skill
on the operator's part
and this is a point i want to raise is
we hear an awful lot about the russian
losses and considerable they are but
there must be losses on the ukrainian
side
will they have enough people left to to
go out to be trained to come back and
take the battle to the russians well so
far uh the russians announced themselves
yesterday um that they lost almost 10
000 troops and then they took it off
they posted it apparently by mistake
then took it off again um which means
that their casualties are probably about
30 000 in total which is a huge total
compared to the 45 000 casualties that
they lost in afghanistan over eight
years so they're two-thirds of the way
to their afghanistan totals in just a
month that will count we believe the
ukrainians don't offer figures and
they're probably sensible that they
don't but we believe that ukrainian
losses are less than half of that
um
but at some point
they they will lose trained people
experienced people and the question is
have they got enough of a of an input
process to get other people trained up
who were not going to be in the military
until this crisis but now they've joined
i mean one thing i would say that the
determination of the ukrainian people is
phenomenal and as anyone who's been
involved in in real operations and real
campaigns will tell you
that two or three weeks on the real
battlefront is a lifetime of training
and do we know are these these
volunteers these um international
legions are they making any difference
are they there in considerable numbers
some numbers um generally speaking they
don't make a huge difference on either
side um partly because they can't be
integrated into them into major groups
now it may be that those who've gone to
fight the ukrainians might be a bit more
integrated into their existing
formations the ones who've gone from
syria um and chechnya to fight with the
russians are just individual groups and
they are not you know they're ferocious
i mean they're thugs basically who who
do have experience of fighting but not
of complex fighting of organized
fighting or discipline they're good as a
little group of vigilantes that's what
they do
those individuals say from you know
armed forces in the west or who've been
in the armed forces in the west they are
liable to be much more disciplined but
the challenge is getting these people
integrated into the into the ukrainian
forces in some way that they can make a
difference so we know the russians are
concerned about that because of that uh
that strike on on the base what was it
10 days or so
yes i mean there was striking at a base
that was used for assembly of of of
people and it obviously did some damage
and i think that must have
convinced the west that they've got to
keep this much more distributed i mean
they had they've had a fairly easy time
so far getting people ready on the
polish side of the border and then
moving them to a sort of depot on the uh
on the ukrainian side and there were
certainly far too many people there in
one place and you have to assume that
the russians will find out about this
pretty quickly you know their battle
intelligence can't be that bad so i
think all of this moving across the
border as and when it happens has got to
be very clandestine and very distributed
okay let's get another question this one
is from catherine and uh catherine asks
does russia have enough military power
to take on the west and this is back to
the the losses that we've been talking
about that the the russians have had
inflicted upon them
and i suppose what catherine's digging
out is you know we're very concerned
that uh after ukraine what happens next
what about the baltics what about
moldova but clearly they haven't been
able to to take substantial parts of
ukraine certainly can't capture kiev are
they really that much of a threat to
other countries not conventionally i
mean during the cold war um the warsaw
pact vastly outnumbered the west in
conventional forces which is why the
west had a nuclear doctrine because we
knew that we we couldn't uh we could
lose slowly but we couldn't win
conventionally and so the nuclear
doctrine was that we will reserve the
right to use nuclear weapons first if
you attack us and that's why the
russians had a plan to actually get to
the channel in three days to have a
massive blitzkrieg through the the fulda
gap the north uh the north german plane
and the hof corridor and they're gonna
be able to hammer blow us in three days
it was it was a crazy plan and even the
russian general staff didn't really
think it could work but they were hoping
that they'd use their conventional
superiority to knock america out of
europe and get to the channel and before
we could use nuclear weapons and say
okay now let's talk that was the plan
now after the cold war the situation's
reversed
it's the west that on paper has got much
the stronger conventional forces and
russia's got weaker forces because
russia is by itself it doesn't have all
of the soviet union plus all of the
warsaw pac countries of poland and uh
czechoslovakia and romania and so on and
so on paper on paper the russians are
vastly inferior to the west in
conventional terms which is why they've
beefed up their nuclear and they now
they now say to us exactly what we used
to say to them if you attack us we'll
use nuclear weapons
because we we know that we will be
inferior to your conventional is
technology altering it as well i mean
you were describing there the old cold
war scenario of these great tank battles
on the plains and the huge number of uh
soviet forces overwhelming those from
nato and the west but we've been talking
about this mobile stuff and that's
technology about drones about these end
laws you talk about about and
uh impacts about a couple a couple of
men
shooting and disappearing taking out a
tank you you don't have these formal
encounters anymore no there haven't been
they haven't been big tank battles for a
long time the last one actually was a
couple of years ago in a way armenia and
azerbaijan but even there it was the
turkish drones that made the difference
in favor of azerbaijan who knocked out a
lot of russian tanks that the armenians
were using what we've got in ukraine and
from a purely sort of analytical
perspective not sort of taking political
sides in this um what you've got on the
battlefield there is a sort of strange
mixture as i think i said earlier of
20th century warfare and 21st century
warfare so you've got a lot of modern
technological elements a lot of
electronic warfare going on not as much
cyber as we expected a lot of
intelligence competition and ukrainians
seem to have much better intelligence of
the russians than the russians have the
ukrainians every time the russians try
and attack the ukraine it's funny old
thing they're not there it's i mean they
are getting information from places we
can guess at but they are very adept at
moving their forces they don't often get
caught whereas the russians getting
caught all the time so there are lots of
other elements to this but ultimately as
as you know the british military been
saying to the government for it forever
boots on the ground really count you
know when you need a main battle tank
nothing else will do
um you can go for modern technology of
course you've got to do that and we are
in britain we're trying to transform our
military between now and 2030 if we if
we've got till 2013 now to do it we're
trying to transform our military but we
may have to reconsider the balance
between the heavy metal
and the the wizkid
cyber stuff okay we're going to take a
break in a moment or two let's get one
more question in at this point and this
one comes from john
uh interesting question why aren't the
ukrainian army using long-range
artillery to fire back across the border
in to russia particularly michael as you
just been telling us so with the level
of intelligence they've got i mean do
they actually have long-range artillery
no that's the point there's two reasons
i think one is they don't have
long-range artillery because when we say
long-range artillery we're talking about
rockets um and the the rockets they have
are anti-aircraft systems they don't
have uh cruise missiles for instance
which are long-range rockets and these
really i mean like the iskandar the
russians got this iscanda which is a
ballistic missile which they use on the
battlefield the ukrainians don't have it
but also i suspect that if they did
they'd be very careful not to use it um
because they want to show the world that
they are defending their own territory
and although it would be a perfectly
legitimate military tactic to go after
uh artillery over the border i suspect
that they wouldn't but essentially they
you know the range of their artillery is
the old russian artillery and their
howitzers are 15 miles 60 mile range
which is pretty considerable if you're
at the other end of them but that's not
you know that's that's artillery's
old-fashioned artilleries range is 15 16
miles okay michael this is fascinating
stay with us of course so we are going
to take a break you're watching a
special question and answer session on
the war in ukraine uh next up a question
on these hypersonic missiles allegedly
deployed by russian forces more coming
[Music]
the surge in prices is squeezing all our
finances with rising fuel costs
inflation and higher food bills
the cost of living is going up and up
how will the chancellor's spring
statement help reduce the cost of living
crisis
the spring statement on sky news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm james matthews and i'm skye's
scotland correspondent
mr trump james james matthews from sky
news hey hey james
diminished by claims that you're a
racist
question i've conducted many interviews
i won't forget
killers among them mr gilroy james
matthews from sky news can i ask did you
kill susan fully i'm all sure that you
know i don't have anything to answer
three of these eight fatalities were
found within the helicopter and were our
colleagues
in the helicopter crew
the whole reception area was covered
with blood one of the reception he was
lying and he was gasping for air
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
scotland has by majority decided not
at this stage to become an independent
country
i've covered scotland for more than 25
years in good times and bad
the headline tonight is that scotland's
first minister
has been deemed to have misled the
parliament the majority vote by
hollywood's harassment committee
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark answering your questions about the
war in ukraine next we've had a question
about nato's capabilities and it is this
if nato
i'm just going to find it for you
because it isn't appearing there there
we are it says uh what defense does nato
have against hypersonic missiles this
from john now we've heard that the
russians claim to have used hypersonic
missiles first of all michael what are
they how do they differ from ballistic
missiles yeah their hypersonic missile
is is is not a ballistic missile but it
is very very fast so imagine a cruise
missile which you know goes like an old
v1 doodlebug as people will be familiar
with um
a hypersonic missile goes at between
five and ten times the speed of sound so
that's between three and a half thousand
miles an hour and seven thousand miles
an hour so it's very very fast and the
theory is that hypersonic missiles go
too fast to defend against they're just
there too quickly the other aspect of
hypersonic missiles which the russians
and the chinese are developing no not
the americans i have to say who are very
late into this one
um
is that they can maneuver they can be
glide vehicles so as they're going
towards their target they can [ __ ]
around so that they're not even falling
on the fixed trajectory whereas a
ballistic missile once you've picked it
up the fact that it's launched you can
pretty well see because it goes in a
parabola you've got a pretty good idea
after a few seconds where it's going to
land so they still be in control then if
they're able to do this how is that
programmed in well it it they're working
on it but even if it isn't programmed in
um they can junk they notice they take
decoy routes before they hit they hit
the target
um this particular one was the the
kinzhal missile which is actually it's
the front end of an iskandar ballistic
missile which the russians have
developed launched from a mig-20 water
mig-31 so the mig-31 which is a fairly
good modern jet takes it to a certain
height launches the missile and then the
missile goes very very fast that's what
they do
nato has got no present defense against
them
there really isn't much defense against
missiles that go that fast because
there's no there's not much defense at
all against ballistic missiles i mean
you know ballistic missile by the time
it's coming at you the most vulnerable
time for a ballistic missile is not long
after it's taken off because it's going
quite slow and it's hot in the middle of
its flight it's in the upper atmosphere
so it's too high when it's on the way
down it's going too quick
so it's it's it's arriving at somewhere
between five and six kilometers a second
very hard to defend against now the the
americans have got systems that can work
against some ballistic missiles but they
can easily be overwhelmed
they could work against three or four
maybe simultaneously but not 20 or 30.
and president putin has been boasting
about his hypersonic missile since 2018
in his state of the union address state
of the nation address in 2018 he
actually ran a long video which is full
of this stuff and he talked over it
about talking about all these things it
was it was a real video of all the boys
toys that he's got um and this featured
quite heavily clearly
he's been talking about it a lot he
wanted to use it in this case to show
that he had it they didn't need to use
it on that target in western ukraine
they used it to frighten nato okay well
let's talk now about non-lethal warfare
well i suppose it can of course uh be
lethal i'm talking about cyber warfare
and uh sarah asks why hasn't russia used
cyber attacks against ukraine and uh
given its much vaunted cyber
capabilities we we would have thought
presumed even as a prelude to the to a
land attack that they might have died
indeed i think we all thought that there
would be certainly more successful cyber
attacks there's evidence that there have
been quite a lot of attempts but they
haven't worked because one of the things
that the ukrainians have done very
sensibly since 2014 and remember you
know ukraine in 2014 when it lost crimea
and the donbass crisis began and ukraine
was humiliated its military was in a
mess it was it was at a zero
and they started from scratch and they
can they turn themselves into a
different sort of power which is what
one of the reasons why president putin
is so enraged by what has happened and
one of the things they did after 2014
was that they increased their cyber
defenses with a lot of western help
and so they've got quite good cyber
defenses it may well be that the
russians haven't been as effective it
and i can't prove this it may also be
that our offensive cyber capabilities
which we now talk about we don't keep
secret anymore but british british and
american cyber offensive capabilities
which are the best in the world
might have been at work i don't know but
i wouldn't be surprised but just about
just kanashima i mean why aren't they
being used as part of their the
sanctions against russia gchq the
pentagon as you say they must have huge
capabilities uh maybe they well maybe
they have or maybe they will maybe
they're keeping it as a as a backup
possibility i i don't know is that is
the simple answer but we are we are
rather baffled in the military analysis
community as to why cyber hasn't played
a bigger role in this war so i think
well maybe because the ukrainians are
better maybe it's because we've uh
britain and britain and america have
intervened in some way maybe it's
because the russians have messed this
one up as well maybe it's because the
russians are holding it back and they'll
do something else and i have to say we
all expect i used to say to people if
there is a really big military crisis in
europe involving russia
one of the
triggers for that will be cyber attacks
on us the few days before you know that
they'll mess up our transport system or
they'll mess up our critical natural
infrastructure in the days leading up to
whatever they do in order to give us
something else to worry about when the
crisis actually hits that hasn't
happened either okay plenty more
questions to get through a break to come
you're watching a special q a on the war
in ukraine next up could be crushing
western sanctions on russia force
president putin into physical
retaliation
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're very welcome back i'm with
professor michael clark and your
questions about the complex war in
ukraine so uh let's get right back into
it and this one is from lee lee wants to
know could economic sanctions
destabilize putin's regime
to the point michael where he might
threaten to attack the west that's a
very good question isn't it because you
know is
an ever more weakened putin therefore a
more dangerous one yes um and the issue
is that at the moment i mean the
russians are taking in three and a half
billion dollars a week in energy money
for the energy they're still supplying
if say there was a chemical attack or
the use of chemicals in ukraine if the
west said regardless of the cost to our
economies we are we are cutting off all
our energy links with russia then the
russian economy would really tank
immediately it's already doing badly um
you know 400 odd uh firms have pulled
out of russia a million people have
became unemployed last week because of
it um if the it's not just the official
sanctions it's the unofficial sanctions
the fact that russia is toxic now and a
lot of shareholders who are very
concerned about environmental and social
and governmental issues these days and
they generally are concerned have added
to that anti-aggression so it's now
environmental social government oh and
anti-aggression as well and so they're
demanding that that the companies of
which their shareholders do something
about it so they pull out of russia
there are i have to say a number of
french companies who haven't and that's
causing a certain amount of friction
within europe but never mind um in
general the sanctions are getting worse
for the russian economy and putin has
got nowhere to else to go he's committed
now
there's no way back there but he could
end up at a court in the hague if he
goes if he goes somewhere else
absolutely across the line so it is
possible and on the you know the best
principle of dictators the best way to
retrieve a gross political blunder in
one place is to make another one
somewhere else on the assumption that
you you create so much chaos that
somehow you think you can manipulate all
the pieces as they fall to earth
and um whether he will try that i don't
know but i mean that's as we were saying
before putin is trying to go nato into
launching some sort of localized attack
so that he can say to the russians we're
now at war with nato and so i wouldn't
rule out the prospect that as he runs
out of all political room for maneuver
that he will become more extreme he's
already saying to the russian people the
west is going to practice a holocaust on
us that's a bizarre thought that the
west is going to attack us and we are
defending ourselves against the
holocaust that nato will uh will
instigate and as i think i said to you a
couple of weeks ago you know the only
the only leader who can save him from
this thing is is china xi jinping is the
only one who can get him out of this at
the moment it's a fine line to tread
isn't it terry keep him cornered but not
so corny that he feels he has to lash
out well people keep saying offramp this
awful american phrase we've got to
provide them with off-ramps a ladder to
climb down and the basic principle
behind that i think is that i think the
west should say
we will back whatever the ukrainian
government will live with if the
ukrainians say no then we back their
refusal if the ukrainians say we'll
agree this this and this we should back
that as well the other ones have been
attacked let's back up their judgment
because that's that's what this is all
about and the west needs to stay uh
united of course in terms of that
response sir plenty more questions
edward asks this what is the likelihood
of russia withdrawing from the conflict
well
perhaps not withdrawing or sticking with
with what they've got somehow freezing
what is the likelihood of that well not
great at the moment but if they are
completely bogged down for let's say
another few months and there is some
sort of negotiated process uh based on
the idea of well let's uh let's have a
ceasefire and let's move out then that's
fine but i don't think a ceasefire will
be very stable at the moment because if
there are ceasefire now the russians
would undoubtedly use that to rearrange
their troops and bring in more reserves
and the ukrainians would use it to rearm
and restock as i would if i was ukraine
um so any ceasefire is going to start to
break down quite quickly they're not
just not the political conditions
haven't reached that point yet where
both sides would want to cease fire
as and when we get to that point if when
we get to it then a bigger political
process might produce some agreement to
withdraw troops but again if would
ukrainians agree to it if they would
fine then we could talk about redrawing
the map of ukraine but even then the
west would be agreeing to let a let a
wicked dictator keep the gains that he
has made by aggression
and if the ukrainians would live with it
i guess the rest of us would live with
it but it would be a very bitter pill to
swallow given that it is driving a
coaching horses through civilized
peaceful behavior and the rules of the
international system
i suppose the other way of getting them
to withdraw is some a battlefield defeat
i mean what are you that has been
discussed it is is this cloud well
the point is that the ukrainian army or
forces are not really big enough to
throw the russians out they they would
need more than they have to either split
the russians up encircle them make them
surrender um
i don't see how they could do it unless
the russians actually ran down their
forces to the point where they just let
themselves be defeated so i think the
ukrainians can certainly score lots of
victories against the russians they can
really harass them and they can easily
even push them back i mean even today
makariv in the northwest of kiev was
retaken apparently by the ukrainians
which actually prevents the russians
encircling it's a really important place
because it actually stops the
encirclement of kiev that's a really
good counter-offensive for the
ukrainians they can keep on doing that
but throwing the russians out is very
hard to imagine okay got more questions
about these uh these offensive and the
defensive reaction stu wants to know
this uh what about those living in small
villages or remote farm houses many
miles away from the invaded cities i
mean is the war kind of passing them by
i mean ukraine's a huge country and a
huge agricultural economy it is and and
the majority of ukrainians don't live in
the cities or it's a 50-50 sort of
demographic um by and large people in
the villages and the small towns can
can survive all of this as forces move
through if they just keep quiet uh they
they will tend to be ransacked i mean
russian troops are stealing all the food
because they're so badly fed themselves
i mean one of the things that president
putin was said to be asking xi jinping
for was mres meals ready to eat you know
combat rations because they've run out
of them in russia so they need more
battlefield rations um so russian
soldiers are well recorded across the
battlefront of stealing a lot of stuff
so i mean if russian
soldiers move through
i mean generally speaking these people
are okay
if they just keep their heads down let
the russians take whatever they're going
to take and let the process move on
it's in the city this is a battle for
the cities now and it's in the cities
where we're seeing the
rasguardia the internal troops the
people with lists who are looking for
the journalists and the troublemakers
and the politicians
and
putting people on buses and carting them
off into russia it's the the it's the
varia who are putin's personal troops
established by him in 2016 400 000 of
them responsible only to him his
personal bodyguard and these are these
are the gestapo of the russian
organization
and those people are working in the city
so if you're in a village um it's not
pleasant but there's a chance to just
keep your head down and survive okay
let's get another question and uh this
one is
from vincent and uh yeah this is uh this
is about uh you know the defense of
mario paul under siege now for several
weeks down in the south very important
uh southern port uh does ukraine need
more military assistance like fighter
jets to defend mario paul i suppose that
ties it together with that issue of
these these jets that were meant to be
coming
from the mig-29s here 29. polish mig-29s
the point is that there was a lot of
nato was it was all at sea with that one
actually politically because poland has
said we'll send them to ramstein the
american air base and the americans can
send them and they can say we're not
going to send them and it looked pretty
embarrassing actually it was politically
very badly handled however the mig-29s
won't make a lot of difference from the
first point is that they can only
operate from western ukraine where
they're safe and mario paul is in
southeastern ukraine so it's the limit
of their range
secondly the mig-29 is quite a light
airframe it's not very good it's it's a
it's an air superiority aircraft it's
not a ground attack aircraft what the
ukrainians need more of is their sukhoi
uh 24s which is the medium attack the uh
ground attack bomber
um if we could give them sukhoi 24s it
might make a bit of difference however
again
um now that the fighting is in the
streets of mario paul
then what the you what the ukrainians
need is troops on the ground i mean
basically they had the uh the azov uh
battalion brigade was defending part of
it the marines were defending the north
the 56 mechanized infantry were
defending the west all those ukrainian
units they've now been basically
breached their perimeters have been
breached they've pulled back into the
center
only ground troops can rescue them now
and the nearest ukrainian ground troops
are 60 miles away so the truth is that
they're on their own
and so what do you think the fate of
mario paul is
ultimately
i
i think it will hang on for a little
while longer
um they don't seem to be in a mood to
surrender and what the individual
civilians in mary paul think the 300 000
of them who are still there
i have no idea but i just you know to
answer vincent's point air power even if
it was effective even if it was sukhoi
24s now couldn't make any difference to
mario paul because when you're fighting
in the streets um bombing from the air
isn't he isn't helpful okay michael
thank you very much indeed you're
staying with us and you're watching a
special q a on the war in ukraine next a
question on the un security council an
effective body or just a talking shot
stimulus
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark and your questions about the war
in ukraine jim has this question it's
about the united nations and it applies
not just to this conflict of course
what use is the united nations security
council is it all talk and no action
well michael certainly plenty of talk
but the problem with action is the way
it's constituted isn't it with uh
certainly on the security council the
permanent members and the veto yeah
that's right the security council has 15
nations five of them are permanent
members who were the victors at the end
of the second world war so america china
russia
britain and france those are the five
permanent members and they can veto and
the other 10 members rotate um so
everyone looks for their chance to be on
security council but those five the big
five in 1945 are the permanent members
and all five have to agree for the
security council to be able to act and
what that means is that whenever an
issue comes up that involves one of
those five it's not likely to get
through if an issue comes up that
doesn't involve one of those five then
it might get through i mean uh 2011 for
instance on libya in march 2011
there was a very strong united nations
mandate given by the security council
which which russia and china both agreed
to to allow nato uh uh air power to stop
colonel gaddafi committing genocide
which is what it would have been in
benghazi i mean you know qadhafi was
going berserk against his own people so
that that was a case where the security
council went along with it
by and large i mean if you look at the
league of nations the league of nations
failed and the league incidentally looks
very likely this is the pre-war sorry
yeah league of legends established in
1919 and it basically fell apart at the
beginning of the second world war
because it had completely failed but it
looks very like the u.n and the big
difference is that the league of nations
found that it did not include all the
great powers because every time a great
power did something awful like the
japanese invaded manchuria in 1931 and
when the league condemned them they just
left and when when the italians invaded
abyssinia in 1935 they left and hitler
just left and so all the big powers are
on the outside america was never in the
league never joined the league even
though to try to set it up and so
britain and france you know two
declining colonial powers were left
trying to enforce this grand idea of
world justice couldn't be done and so
when the u.n was formed in 1945 i
thought it was very similar to the
league in many ways they said we must
not repeat the mistake if the u.n acts
it must act with all of the powers that
can actually make things happen
so it does
but when one of those powers is involved
then it won't so so it's a strength and
a weakness because it means in the end
when it comes to situations like this
there's never any chance of a unbc
enforcer or anything like that so action
can be authorized from somewhere else so
for instance in kosovo in 1999 the un
couldn't find a resolution because the
russians wanted to protect the serbians
in kosovo so nato produced its own
resolution so did the eu so nato and the
eu provided the legal justification
wasn't as good as the un but it was
pretty good to allow action in kosovo to
prevent another genocide in 1999. so i
mean all is not lost but you have to
realize that the un is an expression of
the state of world power at any one time
okay uh we have another question a very
important question uh coming up from
nick about a possible hopeful
end to the conflict and uh this is it is
this the reality uh nick asks will we
end up with an east-west ukraine split
like germany something like germany
post-world war ii is that ultimately
going to be
the way to stop the stop the violence
well if you look at a map and you read a
history book you'd say well there may be
a logical answer here it's the line of
the nistura river which runs south north
to south through ukraine and to the east
of that line is about a third of the
country to the west alliance two-thirds
the east of the line are all of the
russian-speaking
russian ethnic peoples of ukraine west
of the line are the more polish romanian
peoples and that reflects the history of
course because um the east of the of
ukraine used to be part of muscovy in
the the kingdom of moscow the state of
muscovy and west of the line used to be
poland um so you could say well you know
maybe the russians should have east of
the line and
rump ukraine a sort of a satellite
ukraine that would look a bit like
belarus should be west of the line again
that would be a huge
reward to putin in his his desire to
create a nuvo russia a new russia that
looks very like the czarist russia
catherine the great
um
would we agree to it well again it would
come down to the ukrainian government i
mean if they agreed to it i at the
moment i cannot believe in
in a month of sundays that they would
but in wars things change so if they
agreed to it i guess we would grit our
teeth and go along with it
but i i think it's very unlikely they
would ever agree to it unless this war
goes horribly horribly badly for them
okay next question now this from kerry
and uh kerry wants to know this so why
hasn't the russian president vladimir
putin been charged with war crimes well
he's certainly been accused by many
world leaders of being a war criminal
and
even if he were what's the possibility
of him as i mentioned earlier actually
ending up before the court well i think
it's on the way this week the
international court of justice which is
the un's court not the icc not the
international criminal court the insider
court of justice declared this war to be
illegal they said it was illegal and
that case was brought by the ukrainian
government using british law firms
actually who went to the icj and got
them to make a ruling and 15 members of
the icj 13 out of 15 said this war is
illegal the two who didn't vote who
voted against it were russia and china
but the other 13 all said by majority
vote this war is illegal and they
required the russians to stop
immediately now that has no practical
effect except that technically this war
has now been declared by the united
nations as illegal and other things will
follow the international criminal court
has said it's starting to collect
evidence and that's really important
because the icc
russia is not a member of the icc and
the itc can only work within its
membership but the ukrainians who also
not a member and they should have been
but now they've said that they will
abide by icc jurisdiction they accept
the jurisdiction the icc so it means
that any war crimes now committed in
ukraine are within the jurisdiction of
the icc and believe me they are
collecting evidence and there's a this
is one of the more encouraging silver
linings to this whole awful situation
out there in cyberspace there are a
group of people there's organizations
like bellingcat which is run from a back
bedroom in leicester and uh mazzar the
american and orings these are
organizations that collect all this
stuff uh all these photographic images
of of weapons and issues and and
whatever's going on and bellincat in
particular they did this in syria they
collect evidence
and they put it out there to the
community of you know what i call the
military train spotters i mean all of
them men by the way
they look at this stuff oh yes well
that's a that's a serial number on that
and that's a that's a mark two not a
mark iii and they're very good
forensically and the point is they're
collecting all of this evidence they're
checking it with this community
of the military trained spotters and
they're keeping it and they're keeping
it for syria and they're keeping it for
this so if it's 20 or 30 years before
war crimes trials are held the evidence
will still be there and they're telling
russia that they've got yeah so what one
of the things we ought to be doing not
just putin we ought to be saying to
people lower down the chain we've got
you yeah we actually know what you've
done we've got evidence on you i mean go
to the two stars the one stars the
colonels actually get at them and say
you know look at what's happening in war
crimes this wouldn't have happened 30
years ago it's happening now and in 10
or 20 years time when you travel abroad
you can be arrested you can be brought
in front of a war crime shop and we've
got the evidence and you won't be able
to cover it up wonder if you can squeeze
the last one in just very quickly
michael this from john's saying what
happens to a desensitized invasion army
after any ceasefire well we know what
the russians are accused of doing
already ones if they left in control of
substantial parts of ukraine just
quickly well they will be i mean i don't
i mean troops are not always
desensitized by it but troops react
differently after real combat i mean
some most of them are just sort of quiet
and don't say much some of them cry for
the mothers some of them um
engage in acts of of casual violence and
that's what worries people but
some people die in combat some people
give up normality for the rest of their
lives in an injury but everybody
everybody who's involved in combat gives
up a bit of their sanity
michael clark once again thank you so so
much it's been so instructive michael
clark there answering as many as your
questions as he could about the conflict
in ukraine you're watching sky news
tonight and they're coming up at 8 the
very latest from the conflict
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's eight o'clock i'm der mcmanahan
this is sky news tonight the top story
haunting evidence in the trial of the
murdered mp sir david amos the jury has
shown cctv of the accused on the day of
the killing and here's a 999 call made
by one witness
please please quick now the man is
wielding a knife and he's threatening me
he's
killed he killed david
coming up we'll have the latest from day
two of the trial
also tonight over 500 victims of the
post office i.t scandal will get
compensation as the government announces
a new fight
ukraine's president says his country is
on the brink of surviving the war but
that moscow's atrocities continue
there are russian troops who are killing
and raping people and kidnapping
children torturing people and
looting and the metropolitan police face
more criticism with a report concluding
that officers haven't learned the
lessons of the unsolved murder of a
private investigator called daniel
morgan
[Music]
good evening a jury have been hearing
the 999 call made during the killing of
sir david amos on day two of a murder
trial ivany's dialed emergency services
after the south end mp was stabbed to
death during a constituency surgery
they were also shown the journey of ali
harvey ali suspected of the murder that
he took before the attack and an email
sent by ali to mr amos asking for an
appointment
harinad has the latest from outside the
old bailey
the horrors of sir david amos's final
moments are captured in the panicked
voices around him
please please quick now the man is
wielding a knife and he's telling me
he's wherever he's killed he killed
david amos at belfast methodist church
this is yvonne eves a constituent who
had an appointment with the mp that
afternoon making the 999 call that
alerted police to the attack
you see he's always still real too nice
see how can you see how big the knife is
yes even it's a it's a carving knife a
big kitchen carving knife and we can't
try to get it off and he won't be
threatened myself they've threatened
four people here
he wants to get shot apparently he wants
to be a hero he wants the police to come
and shoot him okay we've got lots and
lots of units okay
the jury were played cctv footage that
appears to show ali harvey ali leaving
his home in north london that morning
and walking to gospel oak station he
passes members of the public and boards
a busy train to barking station
there on the platform he smiles as he
interacts with a stranger who's out of
shot
he arrives in lyon c in essex an hour
and a half before his appointment with
sir david
as he nears the church ali appears lost
passing along dre
he wanders to an intersection
but later turns back and heads in the
direction of the church
it's a journey the prosecutions say he'd
researched days before
the court was shown this email ali
allegedly sent to sir david amos
requesting an appointment it claims ali
will be moving to the area and says as
someone interested in christianity i
have seen many churches in my area
losing attendances and struggle with
upkeep i wanted to know if the situation
in south end is similar
[Music]
in the days leading up to the incident
it's alleged ali habi ali made a number
of internet searches including sir david
amos's political views and his voting
history on the middle east conflict and
searching for a muslim burial ground and
looking at a page titled what should a
person do if they feel like their death
is approaching
ali habi ali denies murder and denies
planning acts of terrorism
the case continues tomorrow
asha harinaga sky news at the old bailey
the ukrainian president says his country
is on the brink of surviving its war
with russia as kiev predicts hostilities
could end within the next two or three
weeks vladimir zelinski was speaking as
he addressed italy's parliament today
and revealed that he had spoken to the
pope about the possibility of the
vatican acting as a mediator with russia
but there's been no let up to
hostilities today people living in the
capital kiev have been ordered to stay
at home or in shelters a 35-hour curfew
is in place until 7am tomorrow more than
three and a half million people have
fled ukraine and an estimated six and a
half million people are displaced within
the country
and the american president joe biden is
due to travel to brussels he's warned
american companies that they're likely
to be targeted by russian cyber attacks
and ukraine's president has accused
russia of looting and of kidnapping
children from lev in western ukraine
sally lockwood reports on the siege of
mario paul